c'est l'anniversaire la mois de novembre
donc voilà je venais au mois de novembre
donc le à 200 kw h en ce qui laisse
un délai non je n'ai entendu aucune
information là-dessus donc je suppose et
que c'était comme d'habitude des
interrogations des suppositions du flou
en résumé c'est bien ce qui préoccupe
les centres de contrôle technique en ce
moment pendant le premier confinement la
règle était clair les véhicules qui
devait passer cet examen de contrôle
avaient droit à un report pour le 2ème
confinement le contrôle technique doit
obligatoirement être fait dans les temps
on s'aperçoit que l'ensemble des centres
sont relativement peu fréquentées
parce que les clients sont peu informés
le l'information du contrôle technique
qui est considéré comme un commerce est
essentielle a du mal à passer
parce qu'il ya trop de choses qui se
passent quand on était au confinement de
printemps 2020 alors c'était très
différent parce que les centres même
s'ils pouvaient rester ouverts ne
pouvait pas garantir la sécurité de
leurs salariés leurs clients parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas ils n'avaient pas
tous les équipements qu'il fallait
aujourd'hui c'est le cas gants masques
barrière en plexiglas ou encore des
infections de la salle d'accueil le
centres autovision de bois d'arcy a mis
en place un protocole sanitaire
renforcée
il favorise également les prises de
rendez vous en ligne ou par internet
au jour d'aujourd'hui le client il est
obligé de venir sous peine de d'une
amende de 135 euros
la seule précaution qu'il faut prendre
c'est de venir avec une détestation de
déplacement dérogatoire ou coche la case
2 qui est commerce essentielles ou
encore la cage 7 qui est convocation
pour se rendre dans un service public et
le contrôle technique est un service
public malgré tout une baisse d'activité
conséquente se fait sentir chez les
professionnels du contrôle technique
guillaume clavel la sueur d'ici peu il
devra recourir au chômage partiel pour
une partie de ses équipes au moins 20%